no a la intervención de la iglesia
católica eso es lo que exigen grupos
feministas en bolivia que se
manifestaron por los derechos a abortar
de una niña de 11 años cuyo caso ha
sacudido al país la menor sufrió durante
meses el abuso sexual por parte de un
familiar 50 años mayor que ella y la
dejó en embarazo el procedimiento para
interrumpir la gestación ya había sido
aprobado por la ley boliviana que en
2014 estableció que el aborto es legal
para casos de violación incesto y cuando
corre peligro la vida de la madre pero
grupos religiosos y autodenominados
pro-vida se pusieron en contacto con la
madre de la menor y la persuadieron de
no seguir adelante con lo planeado la
iglesia dijo que se haría cargo de la
niña y el bebé
exhortamos a las autoridades públicas a
respetar y proteger el derecho a la vida
y a la salud de la niña que ha sido
víctima de violación y del bebé que está
en gestación
ambas vidas merecen y deben ser
protegidas desde el gobierno abogaron
por los derechos de la niña vastas
señoras y señores se respeta las
creencias religiosas pero no es posible
que se involucren de esa manera a
decidir sobre la niña
que en este caso como en muchos otros no
ha decidido tener relaciones sexuales
consentidas hasta naciones unidas se
pronunció en la misma línea pues no
debería haber esta categoría una niña
madre una niña es una niña y las niñas
no están para
embarazarse para dar la luz entre enero
y julio de 2020 según cifras del
ministerio de salud se registraron en
bolivia a 953 casos de embarazos en
niñas menores de 15 años en medio de la
polémica la familia de la niña aún no
toma la decisión de reiniciar el
procedimiento para interrumpir el
embarazo mientras el agresor espera por
un proceso judicial en una cárcel de
máxima seguridad